You know, when I was six I stuck a fork
into an electrical outlet because I was curious.
I think that that was the
beginning of exploring the force that
was outside myself that could have physical effects on me and my brain and my reality.
I think Andrew's work blends
this beautiful use of media and
technology and design into these
exciting moments of storytelling.
"Time is Nature's way of keeping
everything from happening all at once."
I'm Andrew Schneider. I'm a director,
designer, performer, writer of NERVOUS/SYSTEM,
which has been developed here at MIT CAST.
Being here at MIT has been different
than other places we've been to.
Most places are venues that we load in and out of.
They program a season and we come,
we do the work and we load out.
Being here is sort of more of a research laboratory.
We're thinking about things
differently here.
When I think about the work,
work I think about the work in not just
this show but about a trajectory of shows.
And so our first show that we made
sort of explores
parallel universes and perception.
And then a second show
explores shared consciousness and what
happens to a human body after it dies.
And this show springs out into what is reality
and how do we interface with it. Some of
the goal is to, sort of, get the audience
to question what is real.
We concentrate more on making you feel a thing or
perceiving your own perceptions, or
seeing yourself see. Like realizing that
you are a being who has perceptions, or
realizing that you are a mind who thinks.
What we try to do is use technology in
service of manifesting humanity, I would say.
To expose the technology then strip
it away and then be left with human
beings in a room together.
This artist in residency program here
sort of gives us
this major advantage over the other
things that are out there, because not
only do we get to bring in artists that
we think are really important in the
current contemporary world, we get to
expose our students to that kind of work
and they get to experience it first-hand.
So even when we see a show at another
institution, we see the the facade of the show but we
don't get to go backstage and really find
out how it works.
He was using tools that
are are really not that different than
what other theater artists are using, but
he's using them in sort of a new and
exciting way.
So this is, I guess, my way
of actually interfacing with a mass of
people and sort of saying "hey, right?"
"Does anyone else experience life like this?"
"And doesn't it feel like this?"
And that's what I think theatre, in it's
essence, actually does
is say those same things.
And I think that I
just happen to go about it in a
different way.